hey John yeah what's up great uh you
work for bloom house right I do yeah
I heard the blue house tilt has a new
movie coming out called the Belko
experiment bomb house tell did acquire
movie called the Belko experiment yes
listen what wasn't wasn't the guy who
wrote and directed guardians of the
galaxy of Aldens oh yeah I do believe
that James Gunn wrote this film and Greg
MacLean the director of Wolf Creek and
various other films is the director of
this movie you know it's funny I think I
recall a shit-ton of people asking me to
watch this like last week and I just
didn't get around to it
well it's messed up why don't you get
around to it because huge humongo
trailers are dropping all last week it's
true we don't make huge humongo movies
we mostly make micro budget horror
this one's rated R for strong bloody
violence throughout yes I've been told
that there's violence in this movie that
sounds awesome
I've know I rarely see a movie titled
that for strong bloody violence
throughout yeah that sounds like an
awesome time yeah that's all I need to
hear let's watch this do it I get all
the other reading reasons sexual
references mmm like caca see there it is
go go
these are his experiments
Bellco is a nonprofit organization that
facilitates American companies in South
America loving our Ryan all employees
lend me your full attention hey it's
Christmas your chance of survival
increases by following my orders
why task is simply this I'm three of
your co-workers or we will kill six
others all the lines dead
we need to evacuate the floor thank you
come on it's a joke now what is doing
this now having all fun at our expense
whoo
[Music]
Oh No Stage one commence his head
exploded from inside
what can we start working you're taking
the tracers in the back of their heads
you must not remove the tag from your
body follow our directives but we will
detonate the explosive begin oh boy hey
nothing you know do you know what kind
of metal this is Oh to discuss all our
options we do not have the right to take
innocent human lives to watch my work
it's me stage to commence we don't need
no more weapons we need to work together
to get the hell out of here [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
in two minutes we want 30 of you dead if
30 of you are not dead
we will end 60 of your lives ourselves
hahaha
oh yeah oh boy Jeepers Creepers that's a
spicy meatball of head exploding
goodness um goodness gracious me though
that's a crazy concept that's a nutty
nutty concept yeah I this is legit the
first time I've seen any footage from
this
I love how everyone working there just
thought it was like a regular office the
trailer doesn't allude to it feeling
like it's gonna be more than that which
I appreciate it like coming over the
intercom and telling people that like I
like the reactions at first or
everyone's like this is just a joke what
the hell is what's going on here so and
someone gets shot in the what oh dude
that just seems like a nightmare to have
to go through yeah yeah I mean this is
this looks cool to me cuz this looks
like an exploitation yeah I'll be and I
love it yeah love it this looks sort of
lean and mean and that's at least what
I'm expecting it looks like it's gonna
be a contained tight fun thriller James
Gunn is fascinating to me cuz like he
came out of Troma and he's made a lot of
like weird indie movies and now he's
kind of inherited some of the the sort
of like you know geek thrown lately I'm
excited to see well it's something
authored by him back in this arena worth
like hog-wild yeah it's like Hogwart
comedy cuz there's definitely humor in
that trailer oh yeah and I love thee
yeah I love like the Pope you flare to
it cuz that's what I liked from James
Gunn like before Agarn I love guardians
at the galaxy I thought that was like
one of the best Marvel movies but you
know that is a very pg-13 kind of you
know fun flick and not that that's
anything bad yeah I think of like
slither when I think of James Gunn I
think of super James Gunn has a sort of
you know zany irreverent style yeah I
think especially to his to his writing
and I mean you know I know there's some
folks out there for whom his writing is
not their taste because it is a bit
boyish of all of his movies that I've
seen thus far there's always something I
enjoy and they do have a certain heart
despite some of the line
mean there's like always like a mean
streak in his movie what I like too is
that the whole cast of characters they
don't seem like cliche characters they
don't seem like they were like so
drastically unique yet just from
watching the trailer but with that being
said they still feel like there's gonna
be something rather rather different
about all them and Michael Rooker
working again with the James the gun I'm
sure James Gunn was involved again and
Tony Goldwyn looks like he's gonna be
the main star but where who's the guy
that I love from [ __ ] John C McKinley
John C me I I will go see anything he's
in I've heard from one or two people
there's kind of an [ __ ] in real life
what but then I never really take
anyone's opinion on that it depends I
cuz I'm like what if thing I was just
having a stressful day what if he was
just having a bad day you happen to
catch him at a bad moment I would be
curious as to this I don't think you can
be just pure [ __ ] and still have a
working career if you were just olya
NASA Johnson McKinley I loved him in
scrubs I loved him in other comedies
I've seen him in he just looks like he's
I don't know what elephant yeah he has
no problem going into the crazy
territory but yeah as I like about this
one this one was gonna get escalating
Lee crazier yeah I mean ice looked like
it added it doesn't look like it says
violence throughout but I have a feeling
it's gonna kind of be like first 30 40
minutes maybe there's like a tad bit of
violence some get shot or something you
know and then the bodies will pile yeah
but then like the last 40 minutes is
gonna be a [ __ ] just insane blood
ride you know III think this will have a
high body count wedding I mean that's
what I'm expecting from this is like a
lean mean high concept exploitation
thriller yeah that's what I get the vibe
from and this looks like one of the
better movies of we know of one of those
horror movies where you have victims
play a game with each other for another
torture or experiment purposes you know
and that's what I'm really curious about
that I have no sense for in this is
what's gonna be the ultimate point are
they gonna try and do some kind of
clever this is what it all means
or are they even gonna reveal that to us
or yeah where is it gonna be just an
immediate sort of herring like they're
there I'm sure there has to be some
reveal but I'm curious as to just how
like crazy intricate they're gonna try
and get with it or
he's gonna make it you know primal and
also it says on I'm tubulin how in 28
minutes it sounds perfect lean and mean
I'm actually really looking forward to
this movie hell yeah that looks like a
blasty blast
alright rejects what do you think of the
Belko experiment would you participate
how many people are you willing to kill
comment below new to the channel reject
subscribe today get accepted John his
reasons to Jerry bloom house and
Facebook social media links are all in
the description box and I want to say
that you can catch our appearance on hit
or miss movie in a minute with the
lovely talented beautiful women Brianne
and Stacey if you like looking at
beautiful women and you kind of like
looking at us then you're gonna love the
videos we did with them they're already
up on the channel and if you like
listening to four equally different but
interesting intellects speak to each
other so now that looks now